now the sanctuary state crackdown comes
as Republicans are reaching out the
Latinos and others who could make a
major difference in November's midterm
elections correspondent Peter Doocy has
that story tonight from Capitol Hill the
new Republican plan to keep the house
house parties I know there are many in
this panic community who support
Democrats RNC chair Ronnie McDaniel is
joining newly hired staffers in living
rooms for meetings with Hispanic
activists and voters in places like
Florida Arizona and Nevada trying to
engage a constituency that broke for
Clinton over Trump by nearly 40 points
but it doesn't always represent a huge
slice of the midterm electorate just 8
percent of totals in oh six 10 and 14
according to exit polls and the gops
personal touch comes as Democratic
primary voters in Texas voted last night
to send to Hispanic women to Congress
for the first time in Texas history
since the Republican Party we're going
to continue to outreach to communities
that haven't traditionally been
Republican that don't know our message
and tell them about the good things that
are happening in this country but the
only way we can share our message is if
we show up the big concerns among
Republicans at a recent meeting in Coral
Gables Florida were the economy and
solutions for hurricane ravaged Puerto
Rico housings of Puerto Ricans are still
displaced and living in Florida which
activists think represents an
opportunity for the GOP we believe that
many many 5-minutes are going to stay
and our job is to tell them how to tell
them the the the message of the
Republican Party the DNC chairman Tom
Perez tells FOX as long as Republicans
are the party of Trump Hispanic voters
will be a tough sell Latinos judge
people by their words and their actions
and this president has made one
statement after another and taken one
action after another disparaging and
demoralizing and disenfranchising
Latinos look at the Puerto Rican
situation Puerto Ricans are second-class
citizens and Donald Trump's opinion but
Republicans think they have reason to
believe
button issues affecting some Hispanic
families won't be the deciding issue in
the midterms the house party that we had
today
immigration did not come up that was not
an issue that any of these individuals
talked about so based on that between
now and November look for Republicans to
try to highlight the economy and look
for Democrats to try to diminish
President Trump no bill it's going to be
here before we know it thank you Peter
Doocy from the hill